eng begrenzte reiseverbote bund und
länder einigen sich auf zielgenauer
beschränkungen für corona hotspots
neustart mit nebengeräuschen bei tönnies
wird wieder geschlachtet und aktivisten
demonstrieren gegen billigfleisch
privacyshield gekippt der europäische
gerichtshof erklärt dass eu datenschutz
abkommen mit den usa für ungültig
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten heute mit norbert
lehmann für den spanische wunder von mir
was tun wenn es in deutschland wieder
regional zu einem massiven corona
ausbruch kommt will man dann gleich
hunderttausende mit reiseverboten
belegen nein sagten jetzt bund und
länder und beschlossen sich in solchen
fällen sehr eng auf den jeweiligen herd
der infektion zu konzentrieren und nur
dort die mobilität einzuschränken
als kritische marke gelten 50 fälle pro
100.000 einwohner in den vergangenen
wochen kam es immer wieder zu lokalen
ausbrüchen zuletzt im kreis gütersloh
die folge waren corona beschränkungen
für alle einwohner für die neue
strategie gibt es ein vorbild nämlich
den bayerischen landkreis tirschenreuth
alexander pohl berichtet am 18 märz
wurde erstmals in deutschland eine reise
sperre zur bekämpfung des corona virus
verhängt es traf die kleinstadt
mitterteich mit rund 6900 einwohnern
sie legte im oberpfälzischen landkreis
tirschenreuth in bayern
hier leben über 72.000 menschen man hat
aus den ergebnissen gesehen dass es
gewirkt hat die fallzahlen sind
zurückgegangen und die ausgangssperre
wurde auf den allgemeinen beschränkungen
wieder angepasst dass es hat
funktioniert
auf solche regionalen
reisebeschränkungen haben sich heute
bund und länder geeinigt sie können in
kraft treten wenn die zahl der
neuinfektionen in einem gebiet erheblich
ansteigt und nicht klar ist ob sich die
infektionsketten unterbrechen lassen
weiter gilt reisende aus einer corona
region müssen für eine übernachtung
einen negativen test vorlegen
bund und länder sollen für eine
möglichst schnelle testung kapazitäten
bereitstellen
wir müssen uns alle so verhalten dass
wir nach möglichkeit infektionen
vermeiden wenn es dennoch zu einem
großen ausbruchsgeschehen kommt dann ist
es eine aufgabe dass wir versuchen die
ausbreitung zu verhindern
überlegungen nach einem vorfall wie in
der fleischfabrik tönnies ganze
landkreise mit einer reise sperre zu
belegen sind fürs erste vom tisch
dagegen hatte es massiven widerstand
einiger ministerpräsidenten gegeben in
deren reihen zeigt man sich heute
erleichtert bin sehr froh darüber dass
jetzt mehr klarheit da ist und dass
diese verängstigung der an vielen
stellen aufgetreten ist auch jetzt mal
weg genommen werden kann
experten sind jedoch der meinung dass es
unter bestimmten voraussetzungen sehr
wohl zu großflächigen reisesperren
kommen kann
es kann schon sein wenn das
infektionsgeschehen zu stark zunimmt
dass man dann doch einfach wieder auf
breitere maßnahmen gehen muss aber um es
möglichst lokal zu halten und da auch
wirklich schnell zu sein ist das erst
mal die beste möglichkeit im bayrischen
mitterteich hat man damit gute
erfahrungen gemacht und kurzer blick auf
die aktuellen corona zahlen in
deutschland die sind derzeit relativ
stabil
im durchschnitt der letzten sieben tage
haben sich täglich 310 menschen neu
angesteckt gestern und vorgestern lag
dieser wert bei 300 von tönnies im kreis
gütersloh war gerade schon die rede dort
ist das wochenlange schlachtverbot
nachdem corona ausbruch unter den
arbeitern aufgehoben worden
seit heute werden im stammwerk wieder
tausende schweine am tag geschlachtet
doch dagegen regt sich auch protesttagen
bode aus rheda wiedenbrück am frühen
morgen werden die ersten schweine zur
schlachtung bei turniers angeliefert
schrittweise wird der betrieb wieder
hochgefahren
nach ablauf der quarantäne durften heute
rund 600 mitarbeiter wieder auf das
gelände
nur wenig später steigt greenpeace den
betrieb aufs dach mit gleitschirmen
landen die aktivisten und entrollen ein
banner schluss mit dem schweine system
fordern sie
der skandal gehe weit über tennis hinaus
sind nur die spitze des eisbergs
das ganze system in frage
der betrieb darf nur unter strengen
hygiene auflagen laufen die mitarbeiter
werden durch plexiglas wende auf abstand
gehalten dazu corona tests mindestens
zweimal die woche
die kosten muss der schlachtruf
übernehmen hoeneß hatte angekündigt
finanzielle staatshilfen zu beantragen
auch wegen des betriebs ausfalls dem
erteilt der gesundheitsminister eine
absage
wir haben den schlachter für auch
ordnungsbehördliche geschlossen und das
ist wieder ein ganz anderer rechtskreis
sie können ganz sicher sein dass die
behörden in nordrhein-westfalen und
freiwillig kein cent an herrn tönnies
bezahlen werden die behörden haben die
schlachtung von 30.000 tieren pro tag
genehmigt aufatmen bei den landwirten
mit schweinemastbetrieb viele wurden
ihre tiere nicht los nach vier wochen
schlagstock wurde es eng in den ställen
jetzt gilt es den betrieb so schnell es
geht wieder im normalzustand laufen zu
lassen und dann halt die überhänge die
es noch gibt dass die nach und nach
abgearbeitet werden die heute
geschlachteten tiere werden erst einmal
im kühlhaus gelagert
denn für eine zerlegung der schweine lag
noch keine genehmigung vor
hier soll ein probebetrieb mit
verbessertem hygiene konzept morgen
anlaufen an mehrere politikerinnen der
linken und eine kabarettistin sind
erneut maes mit todesdrohungen
verschickt worden
wieder mit dem absender nsu 2.0
adressaten sind diesmal auch die zdf
moderatorin maybrit illner und die taz
journalisten hänger jacobi fahrer der
schreibstil entspreche den anonymen
mails die unter anderem an die hessische
linken politikerin janine wissler gingen
berichtet die staatsanwaltschaft in
frankfurt am main
datenschützer hielten es schon lange für
eine mogelpackung und der europäische
gerichtshof hat es nun gekippt das
privacyshield abkommen
es sollte eu bürger davor schützen dass
ihre nutzerdaten bei facebook google und
co überwacht werden
doch das war offenbar gar nicht zu
verhindern die daten landen auf servern
in den usa und dort müssen die firmen
sie behörden wie fbi oder nsa zugänglich
machen über das ende eines umstrittenen
daten deal
und den beginn der großen ratlosigkeit
berichtet felix zimmermann max schrems
kämpft seit jahren für ein stopp der
grenzenlosen datenübermittlung in die
usa der europäische gerichtshof gab
ihnen heute recht die eu kommission und
die usa hatten mit dem privacyshield
eine vereinbarung getroffen die eine
datenübermittlung in die usa einfach
möglich machte der ogh erklärte diese
nun aber für rechtswidrig weil das
datenschutzniveau in die usa
unzureichend sei nach ansicht des
gerichtshofs sind personenbezogene daten
die aus der eu in die usa vermittelt
werden nicht hinreichend für den zugriff
der amerikanischen behörden geschützt
max schrems ist überzeugt die irische
datenschutzbehörde die für facebook
zuständig ist muss endlich tätig werden
facebook selbst muss um steuern facebook
hat es wirklich ein massives problem die
müssen praktisch jetzt auseinander
klempnern welche datentransfers sind
notwendig um zum beispiel einen
amerikanischen freund eine nachricht zu
schicken das geht auch weiter nach einer
ausnahmebestimmung diesem gesetz gibt
aber sonst meine daten die ich lokale in
europa was weiß ich mit einem deutschen
jetzt schreibt die müssen auch innerhalb
von europa dann verarbeitet werden das
urteil betrifft nicht nur große konzerne
sondern auch viele mittelständische
europäische unternehmen die daten mit
den usa austauschen
die digital wirtschaft fordert von der
politik schnell zu handeln
wir bräuchten quasi neues abkommen mit
den usa das die eu kommission verhandeln
muss was dann sozusagen die die
ergebnisse des heutigen urteils mit dem
betracht zieht aber eben auch die
rechtssicherheit für die unternehmen
wieder schafft und das langfristig ein
neues abkommen mit den usa muss her
doch dafür müsste die amerikanische
regierung ihr datenschutzniveau an
europa anpassen die eu kommission ist
skeptisch
wir können nicht zaubern und die
amerikanischen gesetze aus europa ändern
es sind die amerikanischen partner die
darüber nachdenken es nach dem
historischen urteil des ogh ist klar das
grundrecht auf datenschutz muss für eu
bürger auch im ausland beachtet werden
wirtschaft und politik stellt das vor
große herausforderungen
was bedeutet das urteil nun für die
nutzer und die internationalen
datenströme weitere hintergründe zu dem
ogh-urteil finden sie auch in der 10
der f heute unter anderem die empfehlung
von experten zukünftig mehr auf
europäische anbieter im datenverkehr zu
setzen
unbekannte haben die twitter accounts
von vielen prominenten in den usa
geknackt über die twitter profile von ex
präsident obama amazon-chef bases und
tesla erfinder musk verbreiteten die
hacker werbung für dubiose crypto
währungs deals nach ersten berechnungen
wurden bitcoins im wert von mehr als
100000 dollar überwiesen
an seinem stern fasst zusammen
ex-präsidenten präsidentschaftsbewerber
mächtige milliardäre und superstars die
offiziellen twitter-account etwa von
bill gates barack obama joe biden oder
kanye west geknackt mehr als eine stunde
lang waren sie in der hand der hacker
die angreifer gelangten offenbar über
einen umweg an die accounts sie
sicherten sich erst die zugangsdaten von
twitter mitarbeitern und schafften ist
dadurch die prominenten tweets zu
kontrollieren
also sieht ganz so aus als wären es ganz
ordinäre kleinkriminelle gewesen die das
da gemacht haben es natürlich ein
bisschen erstaunlich dass es geschafft
haben in diesen gott modus bei
administratoren reinzukommen wieder
heißt das ist untypisch von daher bleibt
es noch offen ob da vielleicht ein
innentäter mitgeholfen hat gott modus
heißt volle kontrolle
der oder die täter nutzen die profile um
deals mit der krypto währung bitcoin
anzubieten das falsche versprechen wer
etwas überweist bekommt das doppelte
zurück die hacker erbeuteten geld viel
größer aber ist der image schaden für
twitter und den twitter boss jack dorsey
schreibt ein harter tag für uns bei
twitter
wir werden die öffentlichkeit
ausführlich informieren wenn wir genauer
verstehen was passiert ist
das problem ist an dieser stelle das
wahrscheinlich einfach ganz normale
standard funktionen genutzt wurden die
man auch braucht man braucht er zum
beispiel eine funktion um passwörter neu
aufsetzen zu können wenn man es mal
vergessen hat so eine funktion kann man
dann natürlich auch nutzen um diese
konnten aufzusperren für angreifer
angreifer nicht die erste aber wohl die
gefährlichsten bis jetzt das vertrauen
in die sicherheit beim mega konzern
twitter dürfte weiter schwinden und das
wenige monate vor der
präsidentschaftswahl in den
patienten sollen sich künftig auch per
video sprechstunde vom arzt krank
schreiben lassen können dafür haben sich
spitzenvertreter der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung ausgesprochen
voraussetzung sei dass der versicherte
der behandelnden praxis bekannt ist und
die erkrankung eine untersuchung per
video zulässt 367 tage saß er in der
türkei im gefängnis erst nach
diplomatischen druck aus berlin durfte
der journalist den easyjet 2018 nach
deutschland ausreisen
heute ist er in abwesenheit in istanbul
zu mehr als zwei jahren und neun jahren
9 monaten haft verurteilt worden
der vorwurf propaganda für die verbotene
kurdische arbeiterpartei pkk
dj arbeitet als korrespondent für die
zeitung welt katrin eigentlich fast zwei
jahre hat veysel ob gekämpft verärgert
verlässt der anwalt von dennis mitchell
das istanbuler schwurgericht heute
nachmittag die richter hatten ihr urteil
in abwesenheit des angeklagten gefällt
dieser fall war von anfang an bis heute
ein politischer prozess die parteien in
diesem prozess waren die regierung die
exekutive und der präsident fast ein
jahr lang hatte der deutsche journalist
denis hotel ohne anklage im
hochsicherheitsgefängnis bei istanbul
gesessen
erst durch massiven politischen druck
der bundesregierung kam er im februar
2018 frei unter der auflage die türkei
sofort zu verlassen
das gericht verurteilt wird shell heute
wegen angeblicher terror propaganda für
die pkk
grundlage ist unter anderem ein in der
welt veröffentlichtes interview mit pkk
anführer chemie in berlin meldet sich
dennis mitchell aus seiner redaktion per
skype
er will revision gegen das urteil
einlegen
müssen nämlich einem freispruch der fall
also längst nicht abgeschlossen
die türkische justiz will gegen user in
zwei weiteren fällen ermitteln
der vorwurf beleidigung des türkischen
präsidenten bundesaußenminister heiko
maas hat nach dem umstrittenen urteil
gegen den del deutliche kritik an der
türkischen justiz geäußert
die ankündigung weiterer
ermittlungsverfahren sei für ihn nicht
nachvollziehbar
darin zeige sich dass deutschland und
die türkei weiterhin erhebliche
differenzen beim schutz der presse- und
meinungsfreiheit hätten sagte maas in
berlin abschied dank und hilferuf alles
das war der staatsakt der heute
sicherlich hunderttausende spanier sehr
bewegt hat am fernsehen und live in
madrid mehr als 28.000 landsleute sind
im chor ohne virus bisher zum opfer
gefallen der dank von könig felipe und
vielen gästen galt besonders dem
pflegepersonal und all denen die das
leben in der pandemie am laufen gehalten
haben christel haas berichtet eine
flamme zum gedenken an die korona opfer
und betroffene stille unter den 400
gästen die mit gebührendem abstand und
masken gemeinsam mit der königlichen
familie innehalten
führende eu politiker nehmen anteil doch
im mittelpunkt stehen nicht sie sondern
die betroffenen diese krankenschwester
erzählt von den patienten denen man
nicht mehr helfen konnte
schavan wir haben ihnen die hand
gehalten und schluckten und zu tränen
herunter wenn jemand sagte lass mich
bitte nicht alleine sterben vor einem
altersheim findet eine andere kleinere
trauerfeier statt fast die hälfte der
senioren dort ist im zusammenhang mit
corona gestorben auch felix sein bruder
erzählt mittags habe man ihm noch gesagt
dass ein test negativ ausgefallen sei
zwei stunden später der schock
der arzt sagte uns dass sie nichts mehr
für ihn tun können
und kurz darauf erklärt uns der selbe
art dass mein bruder gestorben ist
kein einzelfall die meisten spanischen
krone opfer starben in altersheimen
heute bad könig willi peh die spanier um
zuversicht auch wenn die infektionen
wieder ansteigen
lasst uns unsere kräfte vereinen um mit
hoffnung in die zukunft blicken zu
können
weiße rosen für die korona opfer ein
stilles ein nachdenkliches vermeiden
[Musik]
noch nie war das menschliche auge der
sonne so nah wie jetzt mit dem solar
orbiter eine raumsonde mit der mission
die sonne zu erforschen
knapp sechs monate ist der orbiter im
all unterwegs und jetzt hat der erste
bilder von der sonne ans irdische
satellitenkontrollzentrum in darmstadt
gesendet bilder die die weltraumforscher
feiern denn sie zeigen zum ersten mal
kleinste eruptionen auf der sonne ein
wichtiger schritt um den stern besser zu
verstehen
sicher fasziniert und nun zur fußball
bundesliga norbert und da ist der erste
schritt zur rückkehr der fans in die
stadien gemacht allerdings denn die dfl
die hat den verein jetzt einen leitfaden
zugeschickt der soll die clubs bei der
erarbeitung von eigenen hygiene
konzepten für spiele mit publikum
unterstützen
das letzte wort haben gehört durch die
gesundheitsämter bis wir solche bilder
in deutschen fußball stadien sehen
werden wird es noch lange dauern
in einem leitfaden der deutschen fußball
liga wird eine eventuelle möglichkeit
der lockerung des zuschauer verbots
skizziert ein papier mit diversen
szenarien so zum beispiel die erlaubnis
zur nutzung von 50 prozent der
sitzplätze und 12,5 der stehplätze
so wären in dortmund 30.000 fans möglich
im kleinsten stadion von union berlin
4000 zuschauer das konzept wäre
allerdings ein spielball der umstände
zum beispiel müssten die neuinfektionen
bei unter 35 liegen pro 100000
einwohnern
der plan wurde dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium vorgelegt
die letzte entscheidung treffen die
lokalen behörden
sie müssen viele aspekte berücksichtigen
unter anderem eine geregelte an und
abreise abstandsregeln und das verbot
von alkohol union berlin plante die
zulassung aller fenster einem corona
test diese vision scheint eher
unrealistisch
englischer meister sind sicher schon die
liverpooler aber trainer klopp wer
wollte auch noch den 100 punkte rekord
von manchester city knacken
da aber spielte arsenal gestern abend
nicht mit auch für jürgen klopp war die
leistung seiner mannschaft rätselhaft
liverpool dominierte das spiel und geht
nach 20 minuten durch sami allagui in
führung doch dann folgen ungewohnte
nachlässigkeiten virtual van dyk mit der
unfreiwilligen vorlage zum 1 1 der
ausgleich für arsenal durch alexandra
kassette und noch vor der pause dann
sogar der treffer zum 2 1 endstand für
die gunners durch reis nelson der
punkterekord ist nach dieser niederlage
unerreichbar aber in liverpool wird
sicher trotzdem gefeiert wenn am
nächsten mittwoch beim letzten heimspiel
dieser saison
der meisterpokal offiziell übergeben
wird halbzeit beim tennis
einladungsturnier in berlin die letzte
entscheidung auf dem rasen
die fiel gestern abend matchball für
dominic thiem der weltranglistendritte
aus österreich im weißen shirt setzte
sich im finale gegen den italiener
matteo contini durch und gewann mit 6 2
7 6 zu 4 und 10 zu 8 und morgen geht's
auf dem hartplatz weiter im hangar des
ehemaligen berliner flughafens tempelhof
danke im zuge der weltweiten anti
rassismus demonstrationen wurden schon
einige staaten vom sockel geholt so auch
im britischen bristol
der kann aber soll er nicht bleiben
dachte sie ein künstler und schuf eine
statue von einer demonstrantin der black
lifes matter bewegung das problem der
bildhauer stellte die skulptur ohne
genehmigung auf also musste die statue
wieder runter jetzt sollen die anwohner
entscheiden was oder wer künftig auf den
lehrern denkmalsockel kommt es wird
wieder sonniger und wärmer
die einzelheiten zum wetter hat gleich
katja horneffer für sie das war es von
uns danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
bettina schausten begrüßt sie dann um 21
uhr 45 zum heute journal
und wir sind morgen abend hier wieder
zur stelle bis dahin machen sie es gut